and the Raptors are 0-2 coming into
today as dick gets denied at the
free-throw line Grady dick guarding him
man-to-man he's liking that matchup
showing that he's not just going to be a
Defender
Thompson with the steal
back to Thompson oh and a reverse dunk
for Thompson and we may see this later
on SportsCenter Asar Thompson and that's
why I'm trying to put kind of a little
shine here on what we're learning about
this young man Thompson has got oh an
absolute dime on the outlet pass as they
make positive plays that lead to winning
basketball you see the beautiful Farm
putting it right into
amazing and Rhoden who started hot
nothing there Thompson to follow won't
go turns back up into contact miss that
up strong again and finally it falls
through team point lead trying to get a
stop
Thompson mid-range off the elbow yes sir
yes they move into free throw line
extended Thompson of course deep three
bang at the horn
dick trying to lob it up to Brown and a
shot blocked by Thompson gives up on the
play he was guarding Grady dick but when
he sees his teammate out of position
comes over takes on the seven footer
comes up with the block shot Azar
Thompson getting the job done
offensively and defensively as well with
140 remaining
there's the stop Thompson
here comes the score two he's been
showing off the entire toolbox the steal
and not even giving this one up
taking upon his own self to go with the
left hand